would you say your career
just your own experience is your career
defined by mostly by flaws or by
successes
like if again there's great tension
between those if you haven't
tried hard yeah right and done something
new
right then you're not going to be facing
the challenges when you build it then
you find out all the problems with it
and but when you look back you see
problems
okay oh when i look back um what do you
think earlier in my career
yeah like eb5 was the second alpha chip
uh i was so embarrassed about the
mistake so i could barely talk about it
and it was in the guinness book of
worlds records and it was the fastest
processor on the planet
yeah so it was and at some point i
realized that was really a bad
mental framework to deal with like doing
something new we did a bunch of new
things and some
worked out great and some were bad and
we learned a lot from it and then
the next one we learned a lot that also
ev6 also had some
really cool things in it i think the
proportion of good stuff went up
but it had a couple of fatal flaws in it
that were
painful and then uh
yeah you learned to channel the pain
into like pride
not pride really you know just uh
realization about how the world works
okay or how that kind of ideas that
works
life is suffering that's the reality
what uh
no it's not well i know the buddha said
that and a couple other people
are stuck on it no it's you know there's
this kind of weird combination of good
and bad and
you know light and darkness that you
have to tolerate and
you know deal with yeah there's
definitely lots of suffering in the
world
depends on the perspective it seems like
there's way more darkness but uh
that makes the light part really nice
you